okay how I look at puppet which is more
likely a one or a two will show what
neither a one or it's nor to or show now
it didn't say it explicitly but pop it
flows right on from part a right so the
first part the first half of puppy is
this right is this one here okay so the
opposite neither one nor two we have a
word for this start to the see that
relates up to this event I remember it's
the compliment right it's like the only
way to not have a one or two is these
guys out here make sense so I'm going to
say the prompt the probability rather of
i'm going to use the compliment symbol
which is that big squiggly line over the
time neither one nor two okay that's
going to be and i'm going to write it
because i've said this is a compliment
the probability of copper is one take
away whatever the original probability
was this is one takeaway that so that
gives you answer which is more likely
yeah the first one but huge amount but
enough okay so therefore it's more
likely to have a one or two than to not
as you seen before just like in my
calculus macvean application questions
always look back benchers to your
calculations see if you've answered the
question so that's not too hot party can
you tell me what to do now I held your
hand through a and B where's Part C and
this actually is going to refer to what
J which point out before you might like
to get not coming here or which I've
been do
found the one yep okay good so so I'm
gonna start circling down this column
here right but I stopped here because
what's the word that tells me to stop
very good only so exactly what so I stop
there alright so I can't do this one
this one's out okay I can keep going
though those upon a single for that's
another word you can see and then it all
sounds out of these guys ok does that
make sense so read carefully a single
word changes it right I've excluded the
double which means how many of our
circle wall up looks like Tim right so
the probability of a single 4 is 10 on
36 which is five on 80 it don't ok last
one the question says the sum of the
numbers showing on the dice the song is
less than five so it's less fine ok so
what's the smallest some I could have
the smallest son has to be to write
because I mean wine has to be one every
10 and then the biggest mess up can be
is 0 because again read carefully it
says less than five not inclusive so I'm
looking for all the ones where this time
is to three or four so again be
systematic about it one of the nice
things about laying this happen agreed
is if you find a pattern it will mean
something geometric on here so here's a
sum of two where are the ones with a sum
of three yeah i'm gonna start to form
like a triangle here yeah and then where
are the ones with a suburb for each gig
on ya
do you see why colors are useful just
handy help me not not miss read your own
diagram okay so I've got em all I have
circle all the ones yet you can't be the
colors are for you I was up for you so
you can read this thing thing you can
fit you need your shoulder working if
you've done this right and this comes up
on the scan this is not going to like it
all obviously not all of the colors are
going to come through but like even if
you took a photo of this and made it in
grayscale I can see all of the things I
need to see how this question was
answered or rather how each of these
questions are answered ok so it's
totally get apart again remember the
cause of primarily for you because this
gets really busy really fast uh how many
do I have 6 out of 36 ok lovely now I'm
just going to add one more thing because
um it's the perfect time to say when
you've got a diagram like this one of
the handy things about like listing all
the probabilities or having a dot
diagram that exhaustively tells you the
sample space is that where to ask
questions that included a condition so
it's a conditional probability right
condition or mum is a bit confusing but
these kinds of things make mincemeat of
conditional probability I could change
one of these questions I could take for
instance if I know that one of the dice
shows of one okay I can reassess and
read ask any of them so actually I could
read us all of them if I know that
there's a one how does that change the
sample space so you've got this diagram
now like you've got it it's beautiful
okay if I know there's a one there's
only 11 possible events out of my 36
that exist anymore right all of these
guys they're all gone they can't
possibly be happening because I just
told you I know there has to be a one in
there somewhere and all those ones I
just shrugged off there are no one so
then no longer part of the sample space
so now all these are going to be out of
not 36 but 11 okay and then as you can
see well because I got rid of so many
each
the nuns is going to be smaller okay so
if the first two questions are trivial
because they involve ones okay but if I
had to answer this let's see what supply
of getting a single for if I know
there's a 12 drew out of my 11 you see
how I answer the question in the same
way the same principles when I use the
diagram to help me know what's going on
what about this last one 1 2 3 4 5 out
of 11 okay so you can see conditional
probability it changes this table space
and you use your diagram to help you
work out what the new one is ok any
questions on them if we know that one
dice is definitely more then happen
let's not just like one row two yeah
that's a great question okay um why do I
get both of these branches now I don't
have a written assignments bit tricky
the wedding will generally be something
like if I know that one of the dice as a
one now that doesn't tell you which of
the dice it is right in fact when I roll
I don't even know which one is which
almost like it's a column something like
that now if that is the case right for
example say I have a red dye and a blue
dye okay and then I say to you something
like I know that the red dye has a 10 K
that dollars change the same space again
right if I know the red dye hasn't won
then I have to get rid of even more
right I have to get rid of these guys
does that make sense